here's how to get the ultimate morning
routine in under 60 seconds firstly you
need to move upon waking get outside and
go for a walk walking is shown to down
regulate your amygdala response which
means that you're more calm and relaxed
plus it'll reset your circadian rhythm
by exposing your eyes to light after
that you need to reflect this can be
some journaling it's great for positive
mentalities it can be some breath work
wim hof or state shift or two fantastic
apps or it can be some meditation
headspace sam harris is waking up or
even just sitting and contemplating
counting your breaths after that learn
before you've picked your phone up
before you've got sideswiped by what the
day has installed for you you can read
something that is going to make you
smarter tonight than you were when you
woke up and finally prepare pack your
bags for the day get your gym kit ready
make the food this means that before
most people have even left the door
you've got an entire day's worth of
self-development in it's not even 9am